how you been M me all right you know
you're doing good generally speaking you
know we moved to Florida about 15 months
ago it's been an adjustment it's not
easy I've made friends and I'm getting
in a Groove it's fun nice man that's
beautiful I miss my Sunny you miss you
missed your son yeah I know I'm busy in
Miami doing things you know it was it
was a it was a great run doing the mom
videos you know kind of just stop it
randomly
yeah yeah I went to Europe and then I
don't know I came back and I don't know
just like it felt a bit
uh inorganic at the end you know
like having to like I love you but like
having to record with your mom like
every day it gets like part of me
understands that because I remember
being 20 and I was living in Boston I
was far you know my parents were in
Brooklyn and I was was in Boston and I
went and spent time with them of course
but I wanted my own life so part of me
understands that and then the other part
of me is like I don't I just think we
had a good thing going and it's a
business and we could have kept it
growing the way it was and I I think I
like the the momon dynamic that we have
yeah I I I like it too like it's good
you know it's fun but
um you know it it's just like it was
there's a lot of like just like
you love you love y about and
stuff we don't have to talk about that I
talk about politics and news and stuff
we didn't have to talk about the
transgender phenomenon all the time I I
I like talking I talk about plenty of
other stuff on my channel now it's
transgender well I guess the Channel's
demonetized anyways so I don't think it
really matters does it what would I
say well it's temporarily demonetized I
believe we'll be able to get it back
yeah we'll
see we'll
see but but
[Music]
um this is awkward for you it is yeah I
know you I'm your
mother I mean it's the first time doing
this in like six months so I know but
don't make it awkward how am I being
awkward what did I do I don't know look
at you sip of water awkward sip of
water well I don't know I guess like
towards the end of like the last run of
mom reacts videos it just like I said It
felt really stale I wasn't looking
forward to doing them
and I wanted to just like I liked making
videos on my own better you know like I
I've always told you I didn't want to do
Mom stuff
forever when we were doing them I just
like I cut it off pretty poorly you know
um but I don't know like that's why now
like I feel like now is a better time
like our relationship's fine and
whatever like we um I don't know we were
kind of arguing a bit for a while and
then it's like now you know I made the
decision like it's a better time our
relationship's good like I'm I'm happy
with doing it and it feels
betteru I I listen I said all along I
would like for us to keep working
together and have us both also do other
things we've both found our own way of
that we really like putting stuff out I
like the news the politics um you like
whatever is going on in the 20y olds
worlds and you touch on news and
politics too what I do still want is for
us to do some work together because I
think you're growing up and I think it's
so cool to see you change and your
perspectives and your intelligence and
knowledge and and I I've really enjoyed
watching that and I like participating
in it too so that's where I'm at and I I
would be curious to see what you know
the audience who has watched us want I'm
not looking to do anything that's forced
I don't want to force this either you
know you get gave me the opportunity to
actually do something for my country so
by getting me on that camera for all
those you know those hundreds of videos
we did together you got UNC comfortable
on the camera and you get you helped me
to understand this video World more that
I ever did because I don't have any
experience and um I ended up making the
documentary about you know what's going
on the sexualization of our kids in
schools and I'm out there now you know
doing guest appearances on other podcast
and fighting and making a difference so
I don't need to talk about that with you
all the time it's not something I but
you know I'm also on the phone making
calls and and getting involved in other
political issues and I I really enjoy
that but yeah you're always doing some
new uh so we do need to be fighting out
there like you you're 20 you don't
understand what this country was like
and how awesome it was and how much love
and patriotism and respect there was in
this country we were never divided like
this Barack Obama came in and just and
just like cut cut this place apart and
you you never experienced it so it was
Barack right I have to fight to to to
hopefully save the country so that you
do get to experience it by the time
you're 25 or 30 years old like for the
longest time like I said I just simply
didn't want to do these videos like it
wasn't a matter of you just got sick of
me and it showed but yeah I me that's
what happened it wasn't nice no what are
you going to do what are you going to do
oh yeah you know torture children just
torture their parents and we just got to
take it is it oh I didn't torture you I
just like didn't want to make videos
anymore like reacting to
I don't even do that many like solo
live streams it's just I'll do them
sometimes but it's just not really my
thing like I don't know I think we both
outgrew the
reactions I think that's why I'm saying
you know having more intelligent
grown-up conversations
we started the reactions you were 18 18
years old still yeah 18 you were a kid
it was kid stuff but we're more mature
now Mom reacts to Andrew Tate yeah it
was fun there's been so many different
errors too it was like the mom reacts to
Tate and the funny thing about that
first video is it went so viral that
there's so many like day one people you
know what I mean like red pill stuff you
know like making fun of and
like you know sexy red and those people
great and then the religion stuff and
then I did public interviews and then
the fat G phase like there's so many
different phases so crazy to look at you
know and once in a blue moon you would
let me pick a topic your topics were
just some of them did very well okay
like Mom reacts to abortion you we like
we need to show the people about how
abortions work I'm like why do we need
to watch this like it's just just like
man you know what got annoying to
me about this whole Space is everyone
kind of just says the same and it's
like it the the the regurgitated talking
point was I don't care if you want to be
trans just don't show the kids and I've
said it too but like over a certain
amount of time I just heard it so many
times that I was just like holy
like I just I don't want to talk about
this stuff I wonder if people are going
to watch this like I don't even know you
know what I mean like my YouTube also
got a backend Shadow ban and like my
second video ever did better than like a
lot of the recent ones and the recent
ones are on Niche so who knows if this
video even gets views or have we just
been yapping like have we just been like
talking for 20 minutes do you
think people will watch this like I do
you don't even know I don't know if
people give a that we had a you
know little behind the scenes roller
coaster I don't know but I can say that
I can say that over the past eight
months eight nine months I've gotten a
lot of DMS and comments on my stuff like
hey when are you guys doing a video
together again you know so I do think
that there is something here basically
to summarize this whole conversation and
is we'll start doing um live streams on
my channel somewhat you know semic
consistently like I'm not going to be
here all the time like I live my own
life in Miami where I'm posting you know
doing doing work off freaking day and
then we'll meet up once in a while and
we'll do content like this not reacting
to you know talking shooting
and then post the stuff on your
channel so go subscribe to my mom's
Channel
why you looking at me like that yeah
that's cool why you look why are you
giving me that look what I do wrong what
look see this is what you do I just look
like this is just my face this is just
who I am I if I if I start to talk fast
or talk High he's like what's wrong and
I'm like this is my personality yeah
this is just who I am you should know by
now you've known me from the second you
were born you see this is
like that's all I hear it's all oh stop
honestly like the main thing I've been
focused on is just like business
cuz like we have businesses externally
from content
and my own videos which I kind of went
through like a slump for a little bit um
with making my own stuff and I'm really
back on it now like it feels really nice
being able to post consistently and like
really get at it filming you know what I
mean it feels like like I'm depressed
when I'm not moving forward you know
what I mean I know exactly what you mean
and I felt the same way and I I also was
in a
yeah and I think we're both just like
super active and creating right now and
we're we're creative and it's really fun
you know like it's funny like I think
that the biggest issue that nobody talks
about like worse than porn I I genuinely
believe like scrolling on social media
is worse than porn because everyone's
addicted to it and no one talks about it
and the thing is with social media
addiction
is it's with you 24/7 like yeah maybe
you jerk off like before you go to sleep
or something like that I don't know
maybe some people really have issues
like that but with work like when you're
working when you're doing homework when
you're doing anything it's so easy to
just go like that and click on Instagram
and now your Consciousness is
immediately off of whatever you were
thinking through like whatever problem
you had to Think Through instantly you
can just erase that and forget it and
just look at Instagram and Twitter and
like I had to I did a social media I did
a dopamine detox for a week cuz like my
brain just felt so fried and then I
download
this app it's called opal I'm not
sponsored by them or anything and you
can limit your screen time on it because
like I just didn't want to look at that
anymore so um I just want to add to
what you said so I you know I've been
taken you know I walk the dog a few
times a day and a lot of times now I've
been leaving my phone at home uh because
I just I find myself you know looking at
the phone sometime for our walk
sometimes and I'm not even like present
for a for a walk like it's so
mindboggling and or you know sometimes
even if I have the phone I'll be like
stop it and I put it in my pocket and I
and I look at the sky and I see the
clouds and I look at the dog and I smile
and he looks up at me and he smiles and
and and you know what's funny is like
all that time you're on your phone he's
in the same presence he's always in that
presence of just like sniffing and
looking around and looking at you and
like sometimes you're just not there
present with him yeah and it's sad and
and I and the dopamine Rush from looking
at the clouds and feeling the breeze and
and and acknowledging those things and
how wonderful it is to just be out in
nature like that's a way better dopamine
Rush that I'm getting out of this thing
you genuinely feel after
scrolling like it's so I this why I say
I think it's worse than porn I think
it's worse than anything cuz like I've
had times where you know I've done other
stuff like I've even drinking got up the
next day and I've gotten to work but if
I'm scrolling on Tik Tok for an hour it
ruins my day and so I made this my
screen saver and it's like read go on a
walk with no phone work out meditate
make new like course scripts and videos
make a useful uh Ed watch a useful video
write YouTube scripts short scripts
check in on the networks I'm in and like
journal and like I have this list and so
then when I got stuck throughout
the day I would just come back to this
there's irony and all of that that
we because you know the IR is is my
business is literally capitalizing off
of people looking at that that's what I
was getting at like both of us are in
front of the camera making content to
but that's thing distribute on these be
a Creator not a consumer like that's
literally what I teach people is like
make those brain you know make those
videos that you post on Tik Tok and get
paid $1,000 a million views like people
are making bread right that with that
right now right scrolling I
could care less or go make literal bread
be create something be a creator of
something and not a consumer of media
and you know it's it's actual brain rot
like even when I went to visit my
friends in college and it's
like I don't know I'm a hater for this
one but like I just cannot be asked to
give a about sports I've never
really been that invested into other
people the person I've been most
invested into was Andrew Tate probably
like cuz we would watch
everything he do which is so crazy to
look back at like I watch this
motherfucker's every move I don't even
like watch him anymore which is so crazy
um I still like Andrew shade a lot like
I really don't have a problem with the
guy at all but like I don't know
watching podcast and stuff it's kind of
like the same points that he used to say
you know what I mean like it's kind of
the same stuff I filmed the Grandma's
video earlier and um I asked Grandma
about sneo and she was like oh my God
she loves sneo she's mentioned it at
least five times to me she thinks sneo
was the greatest thing since sliced
bread she she did not like him on
YouTube no but in person when you meet
him in person he is just the nicest
young man oh I could not believe we was
such a sweetheart and she just I think I
think she's got like a like a little
crush on him I don't know you know the
funny thing about where I live is like
all the content creators you watch like
fresh and Fitz Nico like we're all right
next to each other so I see them
basically every single day just living
my life and I was walking with my
grandma and I saw sneo yeah they just
did the the classic for five
minutes like oh like you're on a cruise
like nice and you know just that stuff
it's nonsense but grandma eats it up
I've been a bit more religious lately
too I've been praying and stuff which is
nice you know like start and end the day
really have you cuz I've been praying
that you would be praying yeah I mean it
yeah I have been I haven't gone to
church every time like I keep saying
like you like my friend in the building
I'm like let's go to church on Sunday
and we just haven't gone I wish you
would come here for a weekend come on a
Saturday and come to church with me on
Sunday one time sometime yeah I'm also
like to be honest like I'm still just
like researching religion stuff like
church sounds nice but then you go and
it's like an old man yapping and you
can't even understand what he's talking
about and then like I have a lot of you
know like Muslim friends too so like I I
still have a lot of like research to do
on stuff well every church is different
but like yeah I don't really like that
doesn't like make sense to me like why
is like why is every Church different
like you know what I mean well there are
a lot of reasons but if you just want to
focus on the the priest or the preacher
I mean because it's different human
beings and they have different messages
that they are trying to get to their
congregation because every congregation
has different needs and a different
general
population you know so it it's you got I
I I have really fallen in love with my
church because they just they're you
know he just is so passionate about the
Bible and the messages and the you know
the lessons for us and I always walk out
feeling like I know more about God and
what I'm how I'm supposed to be walking
through life you know and and I've also
been to church where I walk out and I'm
like oh thank goodness it's over that
was the most boring hour of my life you
know so you just you have to you I don't
think you've been to my church yet with
for um for service yeah I don't know I
I'll come with I'll come you got any
final thoughts or
anything yeah it's good to be back yeah
it was fun it was good talking to
you me some meatballs after this
all right go to church we'll be live
make sure you watch the recent videos
that we're posting on both channels like
I'm putting a lot of effort into mine I
know my mom's putting a lot of effort
into hers I'm hosting a live class on
Thursday whenever you're watching this
you can check the the link at the top of
the description is see if there's any
more spots that's where I'm talking
about all my business what I've
been up to how you guys can get started
as well um specifically with like short
form marketing how to grow um how to
grow an account and then how to monetize
it I don't want to talk about that too
much on this channel I want to keep this
really entertaining and you know mindful
content not just short form marketing um
and yeah I think that's about it so just
stay tuned and turn on the Bell because
YouTube has been railing me Susan
doesn't like me we're fully demonetized
even though we haven't made anything
crazy in months and yeah there's a
backend Shadow band so hopefully if
you're seeing this turn on the bell and
I'll see you later